a man called John Arts has been the
director of elections in the city of San
Francisco for two decades before Arns
took over elections in this city were a
bad joke people would routinely find
ballot boxes floating in San Francisco
Bay so orange cleaned up the whole
election process and no one really
denies that but this week San
Francisco's elections commission fired
John Arms Why
well they did it because he had the
wrong skin color and they admit it
as elections commission president Chris
gerdonack told Arns quote our decision
wasn't about your performance but after
20 years we wanted to take action on the
city's racial Equity plan
so that's illegal you're not allowed to
fire people in the United States under
federal law and state law in every state
because of their skin color and we have
an entire civil rights division at the
justice department that exists to
prevent things like this from happening
and we had an entire Civil Rights
Movement designed to make sure the
people were never fired because of their
skin color and yet no one's saying a
word Barack Obama
Jonathan Greenblatt of the ADL our
self-appointed moral Superman the NAACP
not a word no one's paid them to
complain yet
Bob Woodson experienced firsthand the
Civil Rights Movement he's founder and
president of the Woodson Center he joins
us now Mr Woodson thank you so much for
coming on so if you wind up in a place
well of course if because you've just
seen both ends of this if you wind up
back in a country where it's okay to say
I'm firing you because the way you look
it kind of seems like maybe the last 60
years were for nothing
it really it really does Tucker it's
it's and it's insulting and it's
degrading in fact what progressives are
doing is they have hijacked the uh the
the rich Legacy of the civil rights
movement and using it as a bludgeon
against the values of this nation when
in fact it was those same values that
enabled Black America to survive slavery
and discrimination in one sense uh we
are worse off now in the last 50 years
and we have the first hundred years
after uh doing Jim Crow
because the Christ is facing America is
one of values
it is not race
well in of course the Civil Rights
Movement was driven by and led by
faithful Christians Christian ministers
and that whole component and of course
slavery was abolished by Christian
ministers I I never hear that it's been
like completely flipped on its head
no you really don't and you know I make
the case when they just denigrate the
the nuclear family and also Christian
faith you know there's a test uh that I
tried to apply to people if you are run
out of gas at 10 o'clock at night in a
high crime neighborhood and the gas
station is two blocks away
and you have the option of confronting
two groups of people
uh 10 men who came around the corner
and they had just left the bar
and 10 other men who came around just
left Bible study which group would you
want to confront
even atheists don't name their children
Judas
and so people instinctively know
people instinctively know that these
values are important and we were talking
about violence and the disorganization
that exists in our Sinners talk it
doesn't exist all over if you were to go
to to religious
enclaves in this country uh you will see
that there is order
there is respect for family you don't
see drug addiction out of wedlock births
and if you go to any Orthodox Jewish
Muslim or Christian Community like the
United
and you will see these values that
enabled Black America to survive slave
and discrimination still in in place but
we don't focus on the the value
component of these communities and the
fact that they are healing agents there
that that have the capacity to transform
and redeem these communities but what
we're up against is the race grievance
industry and they have hedgehogged they
demonize uh the family they demonize our
Christian values and that's why with the
Woodson Center is doing we are pushing
back because we must de-racialize race
and these civil rights leaders are
complicit in their silence but I saw a
white woman with a black lives matter
t-shirt on beating a black woman pushing
it baby because she was in a trump rally
and yet the civil rights leaders were
silent about that right I'm sorry to
laugh it's so grotesque it's
unbelievable Bob Woodson who has seen it
all great to see you tonight thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight